good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight my block my hood my city
is a non-profit organization in chicago
it's designed to teach kids how to
become responsible citizens now we can't
tell you if the program actually works
but we do know they seem to be aiming in
the right direction last saturday
afternoon four members of this group
went to chicago's bronzeville
neighborhood to hang christmas lights
pretty nice thing to do bronzeville was
once the center of chicago's thriving
black owned business district but at
this point it's just another dangerous
neighborhood in a decaying city how
dangerous is it well as the kids hung
their christmas lights four thugs got
out of an suv and robbed them then a few
hours later someone set fire to a
christmas tree they had set up in a
nearby park
who sets fire to christmas trees well
suddenly a lot of people do
last december the same group of
volunteers in chicago had another one of
their christmas trees burned to the
ground the year before that someone ran
over the christmas tree in chicago's
washington park with a car
so there seems to be quite a bit of
christmas tree destroying going on all
of a sudden what does it mean
well let's see
this isn't just a matter of people
setting fire to balsam furs
a christmas tree is a symbol it's a
symbol of a specific culture it's a
symbol of a much-loved tradition that is
hundreds of years old but above all it's
a symbol of a religion in this case the
world's largest religion torching
christmas trees is an attack on
christianity
obviously it's an assault on religious
observance
by current standards destroying
someone's religious symbol would be
called a hate crime that's a category
much beloved and meticulously chronicled
by the biden justice department the doj
can tell you precisely how many korans
were burned last year in the united
states but they don't keep track of
christmas trees why is that well because
they could care less christopher wray
isn't dispatching a team of fbi agents
to get to the bottom of christmas arson
merrick garland is not going to issue a
press release about it trust us
the media for their part find the whole
thing hilarious
after a christmas display was vandalized
three years in a row in a park in
chicago most recently this past weekend
cbs news produced this headline quote
search on for grinch who burned down
christmas tree
oh so it's a grinch
not an arsonist not a dangerous
anti-christian psychopath no it's a
grinch an amusing dwarfishly cute
cartoon character absolutely nobody can
take seriously
but this is serious these are not
isolated incidents
and they're not being perpetrated by
grinches
in oakland california a few days ago a
still unidentified arsonist doused a
52-foot christmas tree in jack london
square with lighter fluid and then
burned it down
just this morning right after midnight
in the center of midtown manhattan
someone torched the christmas tree right
outside fox news headquarters it went up
in smoke while shannon bream was live on
the air
all right a bit of breaking news for you
tonight you're looking at live images
this is the fox square in new york
outside of fox headquarters it appears
that our giant christmas tree there
just a couple minutes ago was completely
engulfed in flames it appears crews are
there on the scene you see the smoke in
the aftermath as they're trying to get
that under control
so in this case in the case of the tree
right in front of fox news in manhattan
police caught the man they say did it
they tell us his name is craig tomahana
he had a lighter in his pocket fox
security saw him start the fire after he
climbed the tree
why did tom ohana do this well we don't
know
but the more obvious question is why was
he on the street in the first place
according to new york's police
commissioner tom ohana was wanted on
several criminal offenses quote he was
issued earlier this year some appearance
tickets and didn't come back to court
which is something we see all too often
so here we have yet another criminal set
free by left-wing ideologues to
terrorize everyone else this is the
third arson attack on a christmas tree
at least in a major american city in the
past week
time to connect some dots here no
here's the new york times headline quote
fox news christmas tree catches fire in
manhattan
right so it turns out the tree just
caught fire it self-immolated the usual
spontaneous combustion at work in
midtown just like that red suv that went
rogue after the written house verdict in
wisconsin and by itself murdered
children and grandmothers in a parade
because sometimes these things just
happen
it wasn't that long ago you should know
that the new york times was a
semi-legitimate newspaper that reported
the news it wasn't always a stalinist
propaganda outlet designed to confirm
the bigotries of the smallest-minded
unhappiest most self-satisfied people in
america in other words it wasn't always
npr
but now it is and very few people are
still listening everyone who actually
lives in this country knows exactly
what's going on look around our streets
are dangerous much more dangerous
they've been in a long time in decades
there are a lot of reasons for that but
one reason
is our cities are overrun with mentally
unstable vagrants who are living on the
sidewalks
now for a long time we've called these
people homeless but let's stop doing
that the homeless is a political term
which is intentionally devised to
mislead you in fact this problem has
very little to do with homes or
available housing or whatever orwellian
phrase they're using at this point to
pretend these people have no place to
stay a lot of them could be staying
indoors they don't want to because
they're addicted to drugs
it's that simple america has a massive
drug crisis now in progress the rest of
us have been trained to ignore it or
deny it
but it's absolutely real and if you live
in a city you cannot pretend it isn't
andrew yang ran for mayor of new york
this spring and at one point made the
mistake of saying what every single
person in manhattan knows to be true
watch
the fact is mentally ill homeless men
are changing the character of our
neighborhoods
uh a woman
my wife ellen is friends with in her mom
group in hell's kitchen was punched in
the face by a mentally ill man sent a
picture of a bruised face around the mom
group spread like wildfire this is
happening in new york city and we're not
talking enough about it families are
leaving as a result in east harlem the
neighborhood has been changed upper west
side the neighborhood has been changed
we owe our people and our families
better than this and i'm frustrated by
the political nature of these responses
i mean we're not talking about housing
affordability we're talking about the
hundreds of mentally ill people we all
see around us every day on the streets
and the subways there will be no
recovery until we resolve this i will
fix this new york
so here you have an innocent mother
punched in the face on the street now
you'd think the violence against women
caucus might have something to say about
this but no
instead they attacked andrew yang for
noting it andrew yang's comments about
mental illness are deeply offensive
barked teen vogue which is an even
stupider version of the new york times
democratic mayoral candidate mile willy
denounced yang's description of violent
crime as quote deeply disturbing deeply
lacking in compassion
unmentioned was the woman who got
punched in the face by the lunatic
no compassion for her
violence against women doesn't count
when it's the homeless committing it
in the end andrew yang lost the mayor's
race but the mentally ill drug addicts
who punch women in the face are still
there they're still roaming midtown
they're a protected class
according to the washington post these
people must now be referred to as
unhoused individuals or people
experiencing homelessness in other words
they have a right to live in tents
across from your house shooting heroin
with their pants down as you walk your
kids to school
they really think that
when the city of washington dc moved an
encampment of junkies recently one city
councilman described this as quote an
eviction
in other words your streets belong to
them
now these aren't just misguided
attitudes they are suicidal attitudes
any society that gives drug addicts
preference over homeowners will not last
long
in the meantime people die people die
who don't deserve to die
in florida the other day a vagrant
murdered a 14 year old boy who was out
riding his bike
police say the killer is called semi lee
williams he had felony arrests in
georgia and california including charges
for aggravated assault and battery why
was he in jail well because authorities
in georgia in california let him go
so he went to florida and murdered a
child
he appears to be a homeless drifter
spending most of his time in the streets
of miami the incident itself appears to
be a completely random act
we do not have a motive in this case it
appears to be an absolute chance
encounter between
a child on a bicycle and
an animal that probably should not be
out on our streets
it appears to be a random act well you
do wonder about that
but he called him an animal that
probably should not be out on our
streets and that is absolutely true
saying that out loud will not return
this boy to his parents he is dead
but saying it out loud is a start you
cannot solve problems until you resolve
to stop lying about them which we should
do hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else